angelina jolie is celebrating her
birthday on a bright note
and we can't get enough of it you just
have to
fully embrace it over the weekend the
actress and director
stepped out to enjoy a family dinner
with her children at tau restaurant in
los angeles
for the occasion angelina stunned in a
bright yellow belted long sleeve
ralph and russo dress rocking nude heels
and a black
purse oh it's so fun angelina is also
proving she's just like us because it
turns out
she's an outfit repeater she famously
rocked this iconic look during the
maleficent world tour back in 2019
and most recently while promoting her
new movie those who wish me dead
what's it been like as a working mom
throughout all of this uh well i haven't
been working
very very much through through all of
this i mean i've been a working
mom that has worked that is where
there's work
and you know i try to have my meetings
and my briefings and i try to do some
writing
a source tells et that angie's birthday
was a total family affair
starting off during the day with the
celebration at home and then
a surprise dinner planned by the
actress's six children
maddox pax zahara shiloh and twins
vivian and knox back in 2019 angelina
gushed over sharing milestone moments
with her kids
oh it's so fun it makes it you know it
gets quite lonely if i doing it by
myself and
you know it's never fun to focus on
yourself
anyway and so when you're when you're
all taking care of each other and you're
making a game out of it and it's just
been silly and
it's it's nice for me as a mom it's it's
moments and also
watching my kids grow up and watching my
daughter put on a beautiful dress and
and figure out the right heels and all
that mom stuff that's just
you know means a lot and the quality
time with her kids seems like just what
angelina needed
after a challenging past few weeks
earlier this month her ex-husband brad
pitt was granted joint custody of their
children
after a nearly five-year battle angelina
initially sought primary custody
a source told et at the time there are
issues of concern
but the court proceedings are closed and
sealed angelina is always working for
the help of the family
meanwhile the oscar winner has been
keeping herself busy starring in the
thriller
those who wish me dead now streaming on
hbo max
take a deep breath
hold it
and lay back
last month angelina opened up to e.t
about how the role was a healing
experience
well we all have times in our lives
where we feel
broken and uh
i was in a period like that it's been
you know i've had my my share of of
things that have made me feel
um
you know hard to speak too much about it
but just overwhelmed or
broken and so to to be kind of
to have an opportunity i feel very lucky
i wish all women could have this at
times in their lives all people could
have this when you go
i've had it many times in my life my mom
passed away i did want it
you know it's part of something that
when you feel like you just want to
kind of hide under the covers or you're
not sure what you've got left in you
you get an opportunity and i would
encourage anybody to do it you're not a
film actor doesn't matter go
somewhere see what you got in you